yeah it wasn't welcome to this video
playing the Indian King does he play the
Kings Indian maybe he does then cut
shalom zachor milan well he display
something like a king's indian would
seem my place till some kind of modern
with d6 and keep the night back on g8
but
yeah transposing back into a it's a
Solian maroc see bite you have this
position I have had on the board for
roughly a million times absolutely a lot
b5 okay b5 doesn't work because i have
before it still plays it yeah and wide
widths after move 17 unless I'm doing
something extremely stupid which could
happen I mean we know that having a
winning position quickly doesn't mean
you need to win immediately but he's
doing all there is really now is blended
the Queen black resides well now twin
queen bee queen bee sixes answered by a
five and this should do the trick I
Quincy eight not winning the Queen huh
it's enough it's definitely enough yeah
b5 is very very much ignoring rupee one
I want to route between a five is
already bad because it just walks into
this idea white wants to play like this
anyway Group B 1 root C 1 and
potentially before and jam bb5 just
loses the game basically white is too
connected passes now and black has
absolutely nothing to show for it
yeah just a pretty pretty big opening
opening disaster I didn't switch on the
engine but it doesn't wouldn't tell you
all that much white is already quite a
bit better before be five I guess what
is it zero point something yeah it's
just a good maroc seabone anyway ok b5
just I also don't know why to c7 but ok
he didn't think la tienda opening just
dashed out moves and it didn't work ok
guys thanks for watching